Tổ chữ i tệ thời gian bây kết hát ô người mung bắt tháng 2 sân nhận nhóm bệnh nhân
Plastic Nobian đã được sư cánh khói dạ gaza sang ai cập thông qua cửa cửa cửa cửa
Rafa sau khi điểm thông thương này được mở lại ở mức hạn chế
Phát biểu tại Jo Nèv người phân ngôn về kết hát ô quý stiện liên male chubeyet
Về kết hát ô cùng gắt đối tác đã hỗ trợ được sư cánh i tệ jo tiến
Hỗ trợ cửa cửa cửa cửa cửa ra phá kể nóm hành in hai lắm
Chọn 5 yên bà bệnh ở đi cầm trong ai 1 2 tháng 2
Truyện ra nước ngoài đuí trí mong gồm nhiều ca trình thương gió trên trang và mặc li mặt tính
Chào sống này có hơn băng in trẻ em
Phó khi bữa trở trình in trong tốt biết đã có bệnh nhân palestín từ bão
Chỉ vì trở sư tán rú sử trở rú ý tế chỉ ngay ở bệnh thiê bên dưới
Lọc biểu nè tạc
Tối từ Hán Júnés thành phố lớn nhất phía nằm giải gần ra
Bà răng đã abu mức tà phá cùng con trái là những người mai mạnh được sốt cảnh ngày trong ai đầu tiên
Mở lại trở khẩu Rafa
Bà răng trở tối gặp tình đều mắt bài từ chứng trang
Và mất còn lại bị thương trong xưa dọc
Dờ có tối đã mất khi lực ở cảnh ngày mắt
Dù dốt hài nêm qua chúng tôi chưa cửa khẩu mở
Và ông này bộ ý tầy đã liên hệ
Mà bó rút tà phó ra rất tà phó
Há rất tà phó
Mình ám, tôi bị thương cách đây 1 năm bị chứng dự
Só đó ở bị tổn thương thương thương cưng và liệt
Chúng tôi chỉ xin được điều gì
Chúng tôi kiêu gọi mọi người có thể lắng nè tôi
Sì này giúp chả em, lửa ra và phụ nữ
Nè, sĩ bây giờ ra lắm
Các khẩu
Há rất sẹp, tầy đúng rồi
Há rất là lắm
Em muốn được ra nước ngoài điều chiếc cuộc hồi chức năng
Và có thể chả nhạy cho lại
Những bế chả khác, sự quay mạnh
Cô khẩu ra phà gần như bị đồng kiến
Tự thằng năm 2018
Hãy tư khiến các gia bị colp và làm trăm trọng thêm
Cô khoảng y tế và nhìn đạo
Cào dài, nhở năm qua
Hãy ít sợ ràng cũng chưa bị lợt
Tại sao, thật cho phép bộ ngay một trăm năm mình người được sức cạnh
Năm mình người được nhập cạnh
Mà ngày đầu tiên chỉ có năm 2019, được sản ái cập điều trị